on va surveiller une petite interview
lequel des deux voilà à auquel bac 2 ou
david lequel des deux je vous pose une
question sur vos personnalités défaut
qualité vous allez devoir de dire lequel
des deux cela concerne le plus lequel
des deux par exemple est le plus radin
des 8,2 je valide la réponse de david
marsais ce lequel des deux aucun aucun
on est très généreux c'est vraiment
partagé tous partagent tout vous est
offert des petits plaisirs des trucs
avec le 10e temps des petits plaisirs
ouais c'est pas faux car on n'était
certes pas 30 ans lequel des deux
gagnent le plus bas on les sort des 8
toujours qui regarde et on a mis une
chemise et oui oui on sait bien la vidéo
est organisée commencé faisait monter
votre propre société pour fabriquer tout
ça dès la base dès le début on a monté
notre boîte de prod pour pouvoir être
nos propre chef que l'on réparé pouvoir
se sautent au fait quand on gère et
anton a commencé sur internet ont
commencé à avoir des appels des boîtes
de production et en fait quand les
producteurs ne me disais ouais faudrait
peut-être changer ça dans le texte ou
peut-être réalisé comme ça on sait d où
la voie la voie lactée ou la boîte de
prod ceni ou laquelle s'était dit ouah
je me suis oularé pareil et c'est pas
écrit un ça vient de sortir comme ça
lequel des deux fait le plus attention
son look
non visiblement ce n'est pas moi il ya
dès le début lequel des deux a le plus
de succès avec les filles à êtes vous
avec votre gilet vous êtes mariés et
célibataires
oui couple en couple d'accord à marier
pas marié bon lequel des deux se la
raconte le plus haut la voix la bonne ou
douce là raconte moi on aime bien
raconter pour faire ça voilà c'est pour
savoir lequel des deux est le plus drôle
c'est le palmashow le plus loin de nous
deux mais ce général il ya un
cheminement cdec henin qui démarre un
peu le voyez ce que je veux dire qu'à
mêlant réalité puis le deuxième ou alors
c'est vrai maintenant honnêtement ça
dépend des idées ça dépend des sketches
sur draka mais une idée l'autre qui la
voient ou alors ça arrive même que 1 ou
2 arrive avec une idée ça plaise pas du
tout à l'autre mais on se dit quelque
part si lui a eu l'idée c'est qu'il ya
un truc à creuser en fait c'est que de
toute façon j'ai quelque chose à voir
ça paraît très compliqué
vous explique exactement ce qui s'est
passé donc je ne comprenais rien ouais
mais ça va perdre en jeu mais la fiche
comme ça mais vous ne voyez pas ma
bouche et là je dis aux rédacteurs en
chef que change fait avec son chef et il
m'a dit en chaîne à laquelle des deux le
chef à chef jonathan barré notre avis
alors allez y
ouais voilà six tout depuis sept ans
maintenant et c'est lui qui me dit quand
c'est nul quand on joue mal quand on
vois je crois que c'est lui qui dans ton
doux tout ça et le résultat fait que
voilà c on est content
oh